À 16 ans, pour moi,
c'est incroyable.
C'est ma première scène.
Je suis stressée, là,
ça y est.
Je m'appelle Emma,
mon nom de scène :
Emma MRG.
Ma passion, c'est le rap.
Bonsoir, Alès !
Vous allez bien ?
Je suis attendue
pour le festival d’Alès,
faire une première partie
de...
grands rappeurs
qu'on écoute.
Dans quelle merde
je me suis foutue ?
Vamos !
Non, franchement,
j'ai la pression.
Je te dis clairement,
je suis pas bien.
Jour J, un peu stressée mais...
on va pas manger
avant, quoi.
La petite scène.
Pour moi, là,
ça me fait pas peur.
Mais la grande,
elle me fait peur, la grande.
Je veux que le prénom
Emma MRG soit gravé à vie.
Je veux que les gens
se souviennent de moi.
Ça va toujours ?
Ouais !
J'ai envie de percer,
j'ai envie de réussir.
Donc je vais tout faire pour.
Salut tout le monde,
j’espère que vous allez bien.
Alors, je ne sais pas
si vous vous rappelez,
mais il y a quelques mois, j'avais sorti un reportage
sur les rappeurs de
la ZUP sud de Nîmes.
Pour celles et ceux
qui ne l'ont pas encore vu,
il est disponible juste ici.
À l'époque, j'avais rencontré
Emma qui enregistrait
des sons
dans un petit studio
improvisé de la ZUP.
J'avoue que j'avais beaucoup
aimé son énergie
et je suis restée en contact avec elle pour voir un peu
comment elle allait évoluer dans le monde du rap.
Il y a quelques semaines, Emma, elle m'a rappelé
et en fait,
elle m'a annoncé
que pour la première
fois de sa vie,
elle allait monter
sur scène
devant des milliers
de personnes
en première partie de grands rappeurs très connus.
Alors, Emma,
elle n'a que seize ans,
elle est en terminale
et elle vit dans un petit village,
juste à côté de Nîmes.
Et du coup, avec Brut,
on a décidé de la suivre
pour ce moment crucial
de son tout début
de carrière de rappeuse.
Alors là, ici, on est dans
le cœur de Marguerittes.
Alors là, ici, on est dans le cœur de Marguerittes.
Ouais.
Tu sais, moi, j'habite ici
et je suis fière.
Ouais, Marguerittes, dans mes textes, c'est important.
C'est pour ça que
je le fais en abrégé : MRG.
Et d’où mon nom de scène :
Emma MRG.
J'ai vécu avec ma mère
jusqu'à mes onze ans
dans un petit appartement.
Mes parents, ils sont séparés
depuis que j'ai deux ans.
C'est ma mère
qui m'a éduquée.
C'est mes grands-parents aussi qui m'ont éduquée,
du côté de ma mère.
Depuis toute petite,
mais depuis toute petite,
j'aime la musique.
C'est-à-dire que
je regardais pas les dessins animés quand j'étais petite,
je regardais toujours les clips de musique, toujours.
Je connaissais toujours
les chansons par cœur
de Sexion d'Assaut, tout ça.
Ça a commencé...
une petite soirée, tranquille.
On mettait des instrus,
tout ça.
J’essaye de rapper comme
je peux, je connais pas...
je connais pas les bases.
Et ça a été mis
sur les réseaux,
notamment sur Snap.
Alors ça, malheureusement, je ne peux pas,
je suis désolée, hein.
Ouais, j'ai beaucoup de :
“Va faire la vaisselle !”
Beaucoup.
Je suis une fille qui s’habille toujours en garçon manqué.
Donc qui rappe
et qui s’habille en garçon manqué en plus,
je peux te dire que là,
tu es prêt pour le...
le bad buzz ou le buzz
ou tout ce que tu veux.
C'est beaucoup les hommes qui me critiquent.
On dirait qu'ils
ont la haine.
Aussi, beaucoup de critiques, tout ce qui est religion,
tout le monde croit que
je suis musulmane ou
que j'ai une religion alors que je n’ai pas du tout de religion.
De toute façon,
plus tu me critiques,
plus je vais
faire des choses.
Moi, y a pas de souci.
Pour moi, la case départ,
c'est Skyrock.
J'avais envoyé un
freestyle qui avait buzzé
en février 2021.
Ils m'ont appelée,
ils m’ont dit : “Emma,
écoute, passe-moi ta mère,
t'as gagné le concours.
Il faut monter à Planète Rap.”
Je n'ai pas dormi de la nuit.
J'étais stressée.
Je suis jamais montée à Paris.
Grâce à la musique, je voyage.
C’est... Waouh.
C'est un rêve.
Monter à Skyrock
en tant que...
freestyleuse d'Instagram.
Tout le monde
veut passer par là.
Ouais, c'est Emma_.MRG
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Emma !
Il est venu me parler après.
Il a parlé à ma mère,
à mon beau-père.
Il a dit : “Qu’elle continue comme ça.”
- Eh bah voilà, bravo Emma.
Bravo !
- Elle a représenté Nîmes.
Ah ouais.
- Elle kicke, hein ?
- Tu as déchiré.
Jamais de ma vie,
déjà à seize ans...
J'ai jamais cru que
j'allais monter à Skyrock.
- Ça va ?
- Bien ?
- Tranquille.
- Moi, je suis plus fier
que surpris.
Parce que je savais que ça allait finir comme ça.
Parce qu'elle n'a pas lâché.
C'était obligé
qu'elle réussisse.
Faut être naïf
pour croire que...
que ça tombe du ciel.
Derrière, c’est
qu’il y a du travail.
- Si elle se retrouve à Skyrock,
si elle se retrouve
devant la caméra de Brut,
c’est qu’il y a
une raison, hein ?
C‘est pas anodin,
dans tous les cas.
- Et Emma, toi,
qu’est-ce que t’as à dire ?
Sur ton parcours.
Qu’est-ce que
tu en penses, en vrai ?
Tu as un avis personnel, quand même.
- En vrai ?
- En vrai de vrai.
- En vrai de vrai, je suis fière.
- Ah ouais ?
- Sans mentir, je suis fière.
Normalement, c’est bon
avec l’instru, là ?
Attends, je vais
enlever la casquette.
- Tu veux mettre plus fort
le son ou pas. T’es à fond ?
- Eh, eh, objidif...
C'est un truc de fou.
J’espère que je vais
pas faire ça demain, hein ?
Ah, j’y arrive plus.
Excuse-moi, je suis désolée.
- Non, mais ça te fait une
répétition pour demain.
C’est bien.
- Ouais, c'est clair.
- Déstresse.
- C'est... En fait, c'est
tout le truc de demain.
C’est pour ça que je stresse.
Les arènes, elles peuvent accueillir 3500 personnes.
Ce qui est déjà
énorme, pour moi.
Non, franchement,
j’ai la pression.
Je te le dis clairement,
je suis pas bien.
Je suis pas bien.
Ouh !
La chèvre-miel qui allait partir.
Euh, les gars,
j’ai un concert demain.
Tu crois que
je vais mettre la main ?
Réfléchissez deux minutes.
Mais tire ! Putain !
Même sans regarder.
Jour J.
Arènes d’Alès.
Ça va ? Tranquille ?
Bien ou quoi ?
Tranquille.
Ça va ?
Tranquille ?
- Tranquille. Tu vas bien ?
La forme ?
- Eh ouais, ça y est,
on y est, là, hein.
Bonjour.
Salut !
Alors, moi, je ne m’y connais pas trop, je vais pas te mentir.
Ouais, toi, t’as ta pédale,
c’est ça ?
Alors, moi, ouais, j'ai la pédale, j'ai tout, en fait.
J’ai micro...
Micro, pas besoin.
OK.
Est-ce que tu seras capable de faire tes réglages
là-dessus ?
Oh, tu peux le régler, mais...
Ouais, voilà.
Mais il faut que t’essaies là-bas.
- 1, 2, 1, 2.
- Ouais, j’ai un son
saturé, en fait, là.
Peut-être ton effet, après ?
- Ah. T'as peut-être
le niveau...
- Exactement. Je sais pas comment on l'enlève.
- Ouais, ouais, c'est ça,
il est trop... un peu abusé.
OK, tu vas en faire un, là ?
Franchement,
je vais faire le dernier.
Rappelle-moi juste
ton prénom, s’il te plaît ?
Emma.
En fait, là, t’as l’Auto-tune.
Ah ouais ?
Par contre, le micro, tu devrais éviter de le tenir par le bout,
comme ça.
Ok.
OK, ça marche.
C’est pas beau.
Dans quelle merde
je me suis foutue ?
Je ne suis pas prête.
Pourquoi je fais ça ?
Alors que y a un mois,
j'étais tranquille, hein.
“Ouais, je vais faire ça,
je vais passer là”...
Y a tout le monde là,
c'est incroyable.
Et ce n'est que le début.
Ça va être rempli.
Oh, purée !
Ah, y a du monde là ! Sa mère !
Je t'avoue, je ne suis pas...
Je suis bien, mais je ne suis pas bien, bien.
On court de partout,
j'en peux plus !
La montre, elle marche pas.
Tu sais pourquoi ?
Parce que j’aimerais trop arrêter le temps.
Parce que là, tu vois,
je ne me sens pas bien.
Déjà ?
Ah, c’est pour...
Je n’étais pas prête, là,
par contre.
Elle s’appelle Emma MRG.
Faites du bruit !
Bonsoir, Alès !
Vous allez bien ?
OK.
En fait, dans ton corps,
ça fait boum.
T’as des émotions,
t’as de tout.
T’as de la joie,
de la bonne humeur...
T’as tout. Tout, tout, tout.
Franchement, je suis trop contente, quoi.
J’ai de la chance de vivre
ce moment, en tout cas.
Tout le monde se baisse !
Tout le monde,
tout le monde se baisse.
Je veux que
Tout le monde, tout le monde, tout le monde !
2, 3, eh !
Ça va toujours ?
Chaud, chaud, chaud, Alès.
Il y a ma famille.
Ma mère, elle vient.
Mon beau-père aussi.
Mes grands-parents aussi.
Presque tout le monde.
Je fais tout pour rendre fiers
mes proches.
Surtout ma mère.
Cette musique-là,
elle est pour tous les géniteurs de France.
Dédicace à Maman, je t'aime.
Je ne suis pas quelqu’un
qui m’exprime.
C’est-à-dire,
je garde tout en moi.
Et c'est grâce aussi au rap que
j'arrive à défoncer des portes,
à dire ce que j'ai à dire.
Quand j'écris un texte,
ça vient du cœur.
C'est l'émotion en premier, donc ouais, j’ai déjà pleuré
parce que j’ai écrit un son.
J’assume.
Voilà.
Maman, je t’aime.
Emma_.MRG. Bisous, Alès !
Nickel !
On l’a fait ! On l’a fait !
Merci beaucoup !
On l’a fait ! Vamos !
Je suis contente.
Après ce concert,
Emma va reprendre
le lycée,
comme tout le monde,
à la rentrée.
Et d'ailleurs,
il y a plusieurs labels
qui l'ont déjà appelée.
Mais elle préfère finir
de passer son bac
avant de signer
quoi que ce soit.
J'espère que vous avez aimé ce reportage.
Si c'est le cas,
n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner, à liker, à commenter,
à partager.
Et si vous avez apprécié
ce type de reportage,
que vous aimez
qu'on mette en lumière
des profils comme Emma,
n'hésitez pas à nous
le mettre en commentaire.
Je vous dis à très bientôt
et au revoir.
Et pour Brut, allez, allez !
Ouais, ouais, ouais, c’est Emma MRG en direct d’Alès.
Et merci.